welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse in Watchmen is the new series on
HBO a continuation of Alan Moore and
Dave Gibbons groundbreaking 1986 graphic
novel not a sequel to Zack Snyder's 2009
film adaptation though this is HBO dr.
Manhattan can totally expose himself
again and again if he wants to let us
break down and analyze this watchman
pilot episode to explain what this
series is how it connects to the
timeline both fictional history and
shockingly real history the deeper
themes and symbols and yes hidden Easter
eggs because this is a damon lindelof
joint they're all over the place after
this you're gonna be the most informed
nerd and your Watchmen watch party even
if you like me watch The Watchmen alone
let us get started
the pilot opens on a silent film
featuring bass Reeves the black Marshall
of Oklahoma bass Reeves was a real guy
first black deputy US Marshal west of
the Mississippi born into slavery
emancipated into a free man a farmer and
then chosen to be a marshal he served
from 1875 to 1907 major badass arrested
like 3,000 people including his own son
at one point the silent film
immortalized as him in a way most silent
films would never do from that era in
fact there were more famous for
demonizing black people as we saw in WD
Griffith's Birth of a Nation super
racist film the imagery here is a
reversal of the black hat white hat
trope in westerns the good guy here is
in black sheriff wears the white hat but
he's a corrupt lawman who steals cattle
actually foreshadows the mystery at the
end of the episode about Jud Crawford
the white hat sheriff it was probably
not what he seems his apparent murderer
is the boy watching here will Reeves
maybe even related to bass Reeves like
his grandson his father's name is Obie
maybe be his middle name bass after his
father this is set in Tulsa in 1921 the
day of the infamous firebombing of black
Wall Street a prosperous black community
that was destroyed by a white mob that
suspected a black shoe-shiner for a
raping a white woman this is true
history folks it was the single worst
incident of racial violence in American
history not enough people know about it
and now that people were told about it
in their a bush classes in high school
so the silent film that he was watching
is called trust in the law in its
propaganda supported by the then reality
in Tulsa was the city run by black cops
black firefighters black business owners
but during the massacre residents are
being attacked by white Klansmen and
white looters and again not revisionist
history black Wall Street was run by
black people as were many southern
communities in the Reconstruction era
until the Union abandoned southern
blacks and dealed to win the white house
in 1876 allowing Jim Crow laws to take
effect from the Klan to wipe out blacks
from any political influence often via
murder
Will's parents send him away with
friends in a truck but fire bombs caused
it to crash leaving only will in the
driver's orphan baby in this note from
wills father watch over this boy or
watch over this boy it's on the back of
this colored soldier of the state
paperwork with wills father probably
hoping to Oh bear some significance to
whomever will ends up with and will
after seeing that boy earlier holding
the dead baby in the city street he
lifts this baby and wraps it in an
American flag blanket could this be an
origin story of some kind probably I'll
explain what my theory is later let's
move on to the modern era of the Year
2019 the fictional universe after the
events of Watchmen in 1986 so let's
explain this alternate history so we're
on the same page in the Watchmen graphic
novel Richard Nixon stayed president
through 1986 there was no Watergate he
had used the early era Watchmen who were
then called the Minutemen to win the
Vietnam War and in Ex Vietnam as a 51st
state that's why the flags of this
universe had that new circular design of
those Minuteman the most powerful and
only true superhuman of them was dr.
Manhattan who was a God like Superman
figure who became the ultimate nuclear
deterrent but then later on in 1986 a
former Minuteman the comedian
got murdered it was part of a broader
conspiracy by Adrian Veit Ozymandias to
stage an attack by what people thought
was a transdimensional squid monster on
New York it killed a million people
really it was a giant artificial thing
created by a team controlled by Bates
we're all killed off as part of a
conspiracy it was all about tricking the
US and the Soviet Union to end the Cold
War and join forces against an external
threat and it worked
he won during this plot the 80s Watchmen
were the Gentoo vigilante team headed up
by niteowl Daniel dreiberg carrying the
mantle from the original niteowl Hollis
Mason they're nerdy engineers all about
tech driver and piloted a batwing style
owl ship that we see in this episode
also part of that team was Silk Spectre
lorry carrying on the mantle from her
mother the original Silk Spectre sadly
Jupiter in this show and older Laurie is
played by Jean smart she changed her
last name to Blake
after her father Edward Blake the
comedian who actually tried to rape her
mother sadly so obviously there's some
weird dark story going on here stop
being that attack of the time was
another Minuteman hooded Justice who is
now the subject of a Ryan Murphy
Cirie's American hero story so
Ozymandias squid false flag attack was
kept a secret for the greater good but
the vigilante Rorschach uncovered the
conspiracy and before his death mailed
his journals to a newspaper which is how
the Watchmen graphic novel ends so now
in the show 33 years later
Rorschach's anarchist legacy has
inspired a white supremacist cult called
the set of cavalry spelled with a k the
racist letter the 7th cavalry with a c'
from our history dates back to the army
unit of general custer in a Battle of
Little Bighorn which is now a codeword
perhaps to some of cavalry sees
Rorschach as their Custer esque martyred
hero this terrorist group hates
president Robert Redford huh actually in
the final page of The Watchmen comic
hinted that he would be running in 88 to
replace Nixon now Robert Redford has
issued reparations to revitalize black
communities like Tulsa and these
reparations are nicknamed by racist as
Redford Asians the goal of these
reparations is to restore black Wall
Street to what it was and it appears
like they're doing that years earlier
the 7th cavalry staged an attack called
the white knight targeted a bunch of
known police officers in their home so
now cops conceal their identity under
masks so everyone cops terrorists
superheroes everyone is now anonymous
I'll explain later how those blurring of
lines may have led to something very
dark to happen so there's this police
officer
Sutton pulls over someone who he
suspects is part of the seventh Cavalry
he has to get approval for remote
release of his firearm by panda that
Tulsa PD rulemeister it looks like but
it's too late notice that right after he
gets shot the lights flash to create
this rhythmic shaking just like in the
graphic novel the motif of ticking
clocks is all over this series it sounds
like that ticking sound effect it's
meant to signal a character in mortal
danger just as it does for Judd later
moving on to the all-black production of
Oklahoma
how charming so just like Tulsa is now
back to its black Wall Street days
notice how the Church in the Oklahoma
production set matches the one in the
silent film also later we'll see on the
marquee that this is directed by Tessa
Hurston perhaps a descendant of known
black authors or Neale Hurston so the
title of this episode is it's summer and
we're running out of ice it's a lyric
from this musical the song Oh Jodi's
dead Judd was the villain of Oklahoma he
dies he gets a ballad earlier than play
where he moans how everyone hates them
so much that if he Cove himself they
wouldn't bother keeping his body on ice
for a funeral they would bury him
immediately to keep him from rotting in
the summer heat this Jud later explains
how he once played the hero curly in
Oklahoma fact that his name is Jud plus
the title the episode should signal to
all the musical theater geeks watching
this that his death is imminent and that
he might not be the good guy of this
story so judge checks on Sutton and he
meets with the detective Wade aka
Looking Glass he explains that the
shooting was over lettuce judge jokes
were any croutons and then he says star
war oh god damn laughs Wade
this attitude plus the fact that Judd
refused to call in Angela or red are
definitely clues pointing to Judd not
taking this that seriously or at least
wanting this investigation to be a bit
off the books
so as Dredd meets with Sutton's wife the
TV shows dr. Manhattan on Mars he's
demolishing the structure now in the
graphic novel in Manhattan left for Mars
after the events sequestering himself
from the complex of man since his
godlike powers have kind of left him a
pathetic so then Angela aka sister
Knight teaches her recipes to her son's
school class the egg yolks form a smiley
face reflecting the smiley face imagery
of Watchmen but also the overhead shot
of the red placemats kind of reflects
the face in a cowl of night owl there is
some speculation that either Angela or
Judd could be kind of carrying on the
legacy of night owl based on the owl
imagery that surrounds them both glue
Dean Hollis Mason's biography under the
hood on judge desk and an owl mug and
how that hoots in the final shot Angela
tells the kids about separating the
yolks from the whites
perhaps reflect in her jaded perspective
that the white supremacist will never
get along with people of color and she
explains to the kids how she's to be a
cop she got shot on white night but
notice how her kids don't look at all
like her or her husband cow maybe it's
colorblind casting or maybe their kids
were adopted from other dead detective
friends of theirs who died during the
white night I'm Topher gives her an no
mean look when she discusses why she
retired notice in the background of the
classroom there's a poster showing
President Nixon and president Redford
there's also this world map it looks
different than a normal world map that's
because this map is called the Peters
projection map and more accurately
reflects the proportions of the
continents to correct the US and
European biased maps of history another
example of the social progressivism of
the Redford administration there's also
a poster showing the anatomy of a squid
now why is this there well apparently as
we see in the next scene it
means tiny squids from time to time they
are preceded by an AIRAID horn the same
sound effect used for the Tulsa bombings
in the opening scene
now these squids must be connected to
Ozymandias squid monster attack from 86
remember that was a hoax of course so
someone must be continuing to make it
raining squids in order to maintain that
conspiracy so that it wouldn't have been
an isolated event
this could be Ozymandias it could be dr.
Manhattan could be the government notice
that these squids dissolve almost
immediately a sign that they are
probably made out of some artificial
substance Angela gets a message on her
beeper everyone here uses old-school
technology because they associate
digital communications with the squid
attack in New York as Angela heads to
her bakery to gear up there's a
protester holding a sign with a phrase
the future is bright it's an upside-down
Statue of Liberty it's a call back to
the workshop sign in the comics that
said the end is nigh also the Tulsa Sun
newspaper headline says KKK vandalism
forces the Statue of Liberty closure and
that's next to the top headline bait
officially declared dead suggesting that
the bait we see in the episode is living
in secret why is he claiming that's the
[ __ ] him in a second but also there's a
headline Boise squid shower destroys
homeless camp kills too so either these
rainy and squid are deadly or those
homeless people saw something they
shouldn't Angela also passes a mural for
the restored Williams Dream Land which
we saw bombed in the opening sequence
another effect of Redford's reparations
now reading a newspaper is an adult's
will Reeves who asks 200 he's
foreshadowing his Haines of Judd at the
end of this episode I kind of clocked
you at 200 bucks so Angela's alter ego
is sister Knight which is inspired by
Catholic nun iconography she its
crucifix dagger she also carries this
beaded weapon now this is a Vietnamese
weapon called a mala combined with
everything else she's got going on it
resembles a rosary bead her hood
reflects a nun's habit white supremacist
live in a trailer park called Nixon
Ville Angela drags that culprit from
there for interrogation without Judd
knowing the fact that she did that kind
of pisses Judd off as if he didn't want
her to take initiative Judd it shows the
other police an anonymous style video by
the seventh Cavalry and approves the use
of firearms and he says foreshadowing
Lee it's my funeral
Cui's custodiet Ipsos custodes that is a
latin phrase from the original watchman
translate into who watches the Watchmen
their response translates to we watch
lookingglass interrogate see some
cavalry member that sister night brought
in now inside the pod imagery flashes on
the surfaces during this lie detector
test milk the perfect family beverage is
a nod to milk kind of becoming the white
nationalist dog whistle is also an image
of Mount Rushmore with Nixon on it
there's images of Nathan Bedford Forrest
the founder of the KKK Harriet Tubman
and various Rorschach inkblots notice
that looking-glass begins by wiping his
Mirrormask he wants a suspect to be able
to see the reflections of these images
behind him as well and noticed that when
they released the suspect from the pod
Judd lowers his hat over face even
though he's the only cop not to wear a
mask he covers his face here so if he
doesn't want to any look at familiarity
between him and the seventh Cavalry
member maybe now the info that Angela
Pete's out of him leads to this cattle
farm where the 7th cavalry members are
popping lithium batteries out of watches
they also distribute
cyanide pills similar to the pills that
were swallowed by the assassins of
Adrian bait though he was actually
behind those assassins suggesting that
someone might actually behind these
assassins as well through the firefight
they tried to escape in a plane but Judd
intentionally takes the owl ship too far
to burn up the getaway plane before they
can escape this is if he's trying to
cover up something now his pilot is
pirate Jenny inspired by the in universe
black freighter comics inside their
trailer is an old Bank poster featuring
dollar bill one of the original
Minutemen and a racist depiction
throwing a black man out of a bank
moving on to the estate of adrian bates
not dead as a newspaper reported so why
is he living in secret well clearly bait
is up to something his servants seemed
bit off they make a clearly inedible
cake and they think that a horseshoe is
a knife like Janet with her cacti
perhaps they're androids that he built
with anti weapon protocols they can't
carry knives they gift him with this
pocket watch invade to tell them that he
has written a play watchmakers so huh
well in The Watchmen comics dr.
Manhattan John Ostrom Anne's father was
a watchmaker he is literally the
watchmakers son so my theory is that
Veit could be in a similar role as Ford
from Westworld
an eccentric genius tinkering with AI to
play God with a new narrative in Mass
clock maker and this watchmakers son
could be a new road Oh dr. Manhattan
that he wants to generate as kind of a
bizarro deterrent to Manhattan Superman
whom he wants to kill at the end of this
five act tragedy leads mansion also
looks pretty similar to the architecture
of Manhattan's March structure that he
demolished so there may be a connection
between these two at dinner Judd things
that's curly from Oklahoma but as he
does the sound of a ticking clock comes
in it persists over an overhead shot of
the table that looks like a clock and
through Judd saying goodbye with the
words and then the opening credits of
the American hero story program shows
each of the Minutemen and the judge
dresses up as if for his own funeral
with a framed picture of him with
presumably his father maybe a former
sheriff and they look kind of mean I'm
sure that will become significant and on
the ride to the hospital the radio host
talks about Senator Kean the son of the
original Senator Kean the watchman
comics who sponsor the Keene act in made
masked superheroes illegal and now Keene
seems to be running for president to
replace Robert Redford but Judd hits a
spike strip he gets hit by the splashing
light and then later Anjali gets a call
to come find him strung up by a noose
but the elderly will Reid's nearby a
drop of Judds blood
it's the badge just like the drop of the
comedian's blood on his smiley face pin
in the opening of The Watchmen and from
the musical Oklahoma all Judd is dead
plays also if you listen closely you can
hear the hooting of an owl so what
happened here well obviously Judd is not
the white hat good guy he seems to be he
appears to obstruct justice
he's got secrets will stringing him up
mirrors the opening silent film of his
maybe grandfather tying up a crooked
sheriff also involved in cattle
conspiracies I believe Judd could be
connected to the seventh Cavalry in fact
he might even be the masked leader in
that video
notice there I color is similar and they
both chant tick tock tick tock
since both cops and terrorists are all
masks no one other than Judd wouldn't
know anyone spaces maybe there's even
more overlap among cops and members of
the seventh Cavalry just death being so
similar the comedians might suggest as
death was part of a similar cover-up
maybe connected to whatever faked is
planning or the ongoing of squid rain
some of you even suggested will could be
the original hooded justice which would
explain his superhero extreme
and his experience with rope look folks
this is only the pilot many of these
theories could just be [ __ ] we'll
see
I can't guarantee we will break down
every watchman episode of the season but
one way that you can help us afford to
spend more time on finish content like
this is by becoming a patron of NRCS
just check the link in the description
for details follow me on Twitter and
Instagram add a vas thank you for
joining me and who watches the Watchmen
seriously will someone watch it with me
I'm real only
[Music]